हाय गुड इवनिंग एवरीवन दिस इज सचिन सीओ ऑफ
डि फोनिक्स साइबर सिक्योरिटी प्राइवेट
लिमिटेड कंपनी एंड आल्सो द ट्रेनर ऑफ दिस
कैप्सूल कोर्स तो लास्ट क्लास में लास्ट
प्रीवियसली क्या है कि हमने एक वीडियो
अपलोड किया था हमारे चैनल प इंस्टॉलेशन ऑफ
काली नेक्स ठीक है तो वो आप वहां से देख
सकते हो कि काली नेस को कैसे इंस्टॉल कर
सकते हैं हमारी मशीन के अंदर
लाइव करके रिकॉर्डेड सेशन में आपको दिखाया
गया है तो आई होप कि आप लोग हमारे फोनिक्स
अकेडमी चैनल पर जाकर उ क्या कर सकते हो आप
उधर उसके बारे
में इंफॉर्मेशन ले सकते हो और कैसे इसको
इंस्टॉल करना है ठीक है तो आज का मैं
बेसिकली क्या है कि मैं आप लोगों को
पढ़ाने वाला हूं कि हिस्ट्री ऑफ लिनक्स
ठीक है और दूसरा टॉपिक में पढ़ाने वाला
हूं कि डाटा स्टोरेज प्लानिंग ऑफ नक् बहुत
ही दोनों इंपोर्टेंट टॉपिक है क्योंकि भी
चीज के बारे में पढ़ने से पहले उसकी थोड़ी
हिस्ट्री पता होना बहुत ही ज्यादा जरूरी
है ठीक है जब तक हमें उसकी हिस्ट्री के
बारे में नहीं पता होगा तब तक हम उसके
बारे में सही से नहीं जान सकते कि मैं इस
चीज को पढ़ क्यों रहा हूं और मुझे इसका
मतलब की थोड़ा बैकग्राउंड वर्क जरूरी है
उसके बाद बात करते हैं कि डाटा स्टोरेज
प्लानिंग ठीक है जो डाटा स्टोरेज प्लानिंग
भी लिनक्स में पढ़ना क्यों जरूरी है
क्योंकि देखो हम क्या करते अब तक नक्स में
जितने भी चाहे बिगिनर्स हो या कोई एडवांस
होगा कोई इंटरमीडिएट होगा अगर चैनल्स पर
आया हुआ है तो सबके लिए इसलिए जरूरी है कि
कुछ लोग क्या करते हैं कि बहुत सारे लोग
हैं जिन्ह लिनक्स का पता है कमांड्स के
बारे में पता है सब कुछ पता है बट क्या है
कि स्टिल उन्हें डेटा स्टोरेज प्लान के
बारे में नहीं पता तो हम ब्लाइली कहीं भी
नक् में कोई भी फाइल क्रिएट कर देते हैं
कोई भी डायरेक्टरी क्रिएट कर देते हैं
उसके बाद वहां पर उनको कोई स्टील परमिशन
होती नहीं है कुछ खास नहीं होती है ठीक है
और वहां पर काम करना शुरू कर देते हैं अब
उससे होता क्या है कि परमिशन मिलेगी नहीं
और लोग क्या करते हैं कि नक् को
फ्रस्ट्रेशन बोलते कि से हम फ्रस्ट्रेट हो
गए हमें समझ में नहीं आ रहा कि मैंने फाइल
यहां पर क्रिएट की और चल क्यों नहीं रही
क्योंकि एक्चुअल में जो नक् की डाटा
स्टोरेज प्लानिंग होती है ठीक है एक्चुअल
में नक् में हमें कौनसी फाइल कहां पर
क्रिएट करनी चाहिए इसके अंदर जो बाय
डिफॉल्ट उसकी जो प्लानिंग है जब तक उसके
बारे में नहीं पता होगा चाहे आप नेक्स
एडमिन हो चाहे आप एक साइबर सिक्योरिटी
इंजीनियर हो सबके लिए जरूरी है बट क्या जब
तक उसके बारे में नहीं पता है उसकी डाटा
स्टोरेज प्लानिंग के बारे में नहीं पता है
तब तक आपको क्या है कोई बेनिफिट नहीं होगा
क्योंकि आप ब्लाइंड कहीं भी करते रहो
तुक्का मार के उसके बाद दूसरी फाइल क्रिएट
कर दी तीसरी कर दी फालतू मेमोरी भरनी होती
है तो हमारी इंस्टॉलेशन वीडियो ऑलरेडी
प्लीज कर लीजिए ठीक है क्योंकि हमारे पास
जितने डेज का है कैप्सूल कोर्स है काफी
अच्छे से सब कुछ प्रैक्टिकली रहेगा तो अब
उसमें क्या कि थोड़ा प्रैक्टिकल रहेगा तो
वहां से आप क्या कर लीजिए उसको इंस्टॉलेशन
प्रोसेस दे के काम कर लीजिए अब मैं आपको
मेरी वाइट बोर्ड प लेकर जा रहा हूं आपकी
ब्लैक स्क्रीन प लेक जा रहा हूं वहां पर
मैं आपको थोड़ा सा टिकल पार्ट रहेगा आज
क्योंकि बहुत इंपोर्टेंट पार्ट है यह नहीं
पता होगा तब तक आपको नक् पढ़ने का कोई
फायदा नहीं है किसी भी नक् एडमिन के लिए
भले ही चाहे आप कोई भी साइबर सिक्योरिटी
इंजीनियर हो तो मैं आपको लेकर जा रहा हूं
मेरी स्क्रीन पर एक
मिनट ओके फुल स्क्रीन ओके ठीक है तो सबसे
पहले हम हिस्ट्री ऑफ लिनक्स के बारे में
पढ़ने वाले हैं हिस्ट्री ऑफ लिनक्स क्या
है ठीक
है हिस्ट्री
ऑफ
नक्स हिस्ट्री ऑफ लेनेक्स के बारे में हम
पढ़ने वाले हैं अब
करते हम बिल्कुल स्टार्टिंग से कि लिनक्स
की हिस्ट्री क्या है थोड़ा इंटरेस्टिंग है
तो उसके बारे में पढ़ते
हैं आई होप सबको मेरी स्क्रीन सब विजिबल
होगी और सबको मेरे क्या है कि जो वॉइस है
वह भी क्लियर होगी तो अब स्टार्ट करते हैं
देखो स्टार्टिंग क से हुई की
1964 ठीक है
19 64 ठीक है बे लेबोरेटरी के अंदर 64 में
बे लबरेट
बेल लेबोरेटरी के अंदर
जो न्यू जर्सी के अंदर ठीक है बेल
लेबोरेटरी में न्यू जर्सी के
अंदर न्यू जर्सी ए आर एस वाई ठीक है न्यू
जर्सी के अंदर क्या है कि एक प्रोजेक्ट चल
रहा था इसके अंदर एक प्रोजेक्ट चल रहा था
और इसका इस प्रोजेक्ट का पर्पस क्या था इस
प्रोजेक्ट का मेन परपस था कि एक ऐसा
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम बनाया जाए जो मल्टी यूजर
हो
मतलब क्या है कि मल्टी यूजर का कि उस
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को मल्टीपल यूजर यूज कर
पाए ठीक है एक ही मशीन के अंदर मल्टीपल
यूजर उसको यूज कर पाए इस परपज से एक ऐसे
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को बनाने की प्लानिंग चल
रही थी अब क्या हुआ
कि
19 69 में क्या कर दिया इस प्रोजेक्ट को
विडा कर दिया
गया विडा दिस
प्रोजेक्ट दिस प्रोजेक्ट इस प्रोजेक्ट
क्या कर दिया विथ ड्रा कर दिया गया मतलब
हटा दिया गया अब इस प्रोजेक्ट के में क्या
थे दो महत्त्वपूर्ण इंसान इसके पार्ट थे
मेंबर थे ठीक है जिनका नाम था एक तो
डेनिस डेनिस रिच आर आई सी एच ई डेनिस रिच
एंड केन थॉमसन
केन थॉमसन सर ठीक है दोनों सर प्रेजेंट थे
इसमें ठीक है तो अब यह सेटिस्फाई नहीं थे
इस चीज से यह सेटिस्फाई नहीं थे इस चीज से
कि जो हम जो हमने काम करना शुरू किया था
बीच में बंद कर दिया गया ठीक है अब होता
ना कुछ लोगों को सेटिस्फेक्शन नहीं मिलता
तो उन्होंने क्या कर दिया इस परे काम करना
फिर से शुरू कर दिया उन्होंने क्या कर
दिया इस प्रोजेक्ट को फिर से स्टार्टिंग
से स्टार्ट कर दिया हालांकि 1969 में
प्रोजेक्ट को विथ ड्रा कर दिया गया था बल
लेबोरेटरी के द्वारा बट क्या हुआ कि इन दो
इन दोनों ने डेनिस रिची एंड कन थॉमसन ने
इसके ऊपर काम करना शुरू कर दिया और
इन्होने फाइनली क्या कर दिया एक ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम बना दिया ठीक है एक ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम बना दिया जिसका नाम
था यूनिस ठीक है यूनिक्स को जिसके नाम से
हम जानते हैं ठीक है एक्चुअल में हम जो
जानते हैं जिस नाम से हम जानते हैं वह नाम
है यूनिक्स ठीक है वो नाम है यूनिक्स बट
क्या है कि एक्चुअल में जो इसका नाम है वो
है यू एन आई सी एस यूनिक्स ठीक है ये है
बट हमने धीरे-धीरे क्या बोलना ऐसे शुरू कर
दिया कि य एन आई सी एस को हमने क्या बता
दिया य एन आई एक्स अब इसकी फुल फॉर्म क्या
थी इसकी फुल फॉर्म
थी यूनि
पलेक्स यूनि फलेक्स
इंफॉर्मेशन
एंड कंप्यूटिंग सर्विस
एंड कंप्यूटिंग
सर्विस कंप इसकी फुल फॉर्म थी ये एक प्री
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम था ठीक है
एक फ्री ओएस था प्लस में ओपन सोर्स था ओपन
सोर्स ओपन सोर्स का मतलब क्या होता है कि
इसका सोर्स कोड जो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम का कोड
है सोर्स कोड कोई भी रिव्यू कर सकता है
उसमें कोई भी चेंजेज कर सकता है अपनी
जरूरत के हिसाब से अपनी नीड के हिसाब से
ठीक
है ठीक है
वह तो वो क्या है जरूरत के हिसाब से हम
क्या कर सकते
उसको मॉडिफाई कर सकते थे तो अब बात करते
हैं हम नेक्स्ट इसी में कंटिन्यू चलते हैं
अब 1975 में क्या हुआ
कि
1975 में इसका एक और वर्जन आया ठीक है
यूनिक्स
वर्जन v6 जो काफी पॉपुलर हुआ था उन उन डेज
में और इसी टाइम पर क्या हुआ 1975 के
आसपास बहुत सारी कंपनिया मार्केट में आई
जिन्होंने क्या किया कि जिन्होंने इस
कमर्शियल इसके जो यह था क्या य ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम था जो बनाया गया था
दोनों डेनिस रिची एंड केन थॉमसन के द्वारा
उन्होंने इन्होने क्या कर दिया उसके
कमर्शियल वर्जन बनाने शुरू कर दिए 1970 के
आसपास क् कंपनी को भी बेनिफिट उठाना था
इन्होने क्या कर दिया यिस के वर्जन ले आए
मार्केट में जिनको हम बोलते हैं फ्लेवर्स
ऑफ यूनिक्स ठीक है फ्लेवर ऑफ यूनिक्स
यूनिक्स को कौन-कौन से फ्लेव थे उस टाइम
पर
प्रेजेंट पहला तो था जैसे कि आईबीएम ए
एक्स ठीक है उसके बाद सन सिस्टम के
द्वारा बनाया गया सन सोलरेज
सन लरेस उसके बाद एक मैक ओस आया एल कंपनी
के द्वारा उसके बाद आया
एचपी य एक्स मतलब कि यह क्या है य के कुछ
फ्लेवर्स थे जो उन कंपनियों ने क्या किया
कमर्शियल वर्जन बना दिए गए अब बात करते
हैं यह तो थी हमारी थोड़ी सी हिस्ट्री ऑफ
यूनिक्स अब जो एक्चुअल बात करने वाले हम
लिनक्स की हिस्ट्री के बारे में ठीक है
क्योंकि अब बहुत सारे लोग बोलते हैं कि
नक्स ड्राइव किया गया है यूनिक से बट
ट्रुथ और कुछ है आज उस उसके बारे में बात
करने वाले हैं अब हुआ क्या था
कि कि 1991 में ठीक है
1991 वन में एक स्टूडेंट
थे लास
लाइनेक्स टोर वेल्ट ठीक है लेनिस स्टोर
वल्ड नाम के एक स्टूडेंट थे व अपनी पढ़ाई
कर रहे थे यूनिवर्सिटी में और उनको कोई
प्रोजेक्ट दिया गया था और उस प्रोजेक्ट
में उन्हें किसी ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को यूज
करना था ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम की रिक्वायरमेंट
थी अब उन्होंने देखा कि मार्केट में
यूनिक्स ओल्ड हो चुका है और जो पेड जो
वर्जन अवेलेबल है कमर्शियल वर्जन वह काफी
महंगे हैं उस टाइम पर 000 भी काफी होते थे
तो वो काफी महंगे हैं तो उन्होंने क्या
सोचा कि जब हर एक कंपनी खुद के
यूनिक्स बेस ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम बना सकती है
क्यों ना मैं ना बना लू तो उन्होंने क्या
किया कि उन्होंने अपना खुद का ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम बनाना शुरू कर दिया ठीक है खुद का
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम बनाना शुरू कर दिया जिसका
नाम था लाइक्स ठीक है जिसका नाम लाइक्स
इन्हीं के इस इन्हीं के नाम से ड्राइव
किया गया ये लाइक्स ठीक है लाइक्स रवर्ल्ड
के नाम से लाइक्स ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम उसका
नाम रखा गया अब मैं ऐसा क्यों बोल रहा हूं
कि यह यक्स ने ड्राई किया क्योंकि देखो
प्रीवियसली जो जितने भी कंपनियों ने
कमर्शियल वर्जन बनाए उन्होंने क्या कर
दिया जो यूनिक था उसको क्या कर दिया सोर्स
कोड को थोड़ा बहुत मॉडिफाई किया उसमें
चेंजेज किए और अपने अपने वर्जन निकाल दिए
लेकिन इन्होंने क्या किया इसमें इन्होंने
इसमें इन्होंने क्या किया लिनक्स का पूरा
का पूरा कोड क्या ना सोर्स कोड स्क्रैच से
लिखा था स्टार्टिंग से स्क्रैच से पूरा
कोड लिखा था ठीक है उन्होंने मॉडिफाई नहीं
किया यक्स कोड को उन्होंने पूरा पूरा कोड
खुद से लिखा था लिनक्स ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के
लिए हां अंडरस्टैंडिंग परपस से उन्होंने
क्या किया यूनिक्स का यूज किया कि
अंडरस्टैंडिंग कैसे काम कर रहा है कैसे
इसका सोर्स कोड है बट उन्होंने क्या कि
पूरा को सोर्स स्टार्टिंग से लिखा था
लेकिन उन्होंने क्या किया था एक चीज की थी
उन्होंने ने सबसे ज्यादा यूनिक्स की
बजाय एक नाम है यूनिक्स की बजाय उन्होंने
पढ़ा सबसे ज्यादा
एंड्रू
एंड्रू ने ने बम एंड्र तेने बम को ज्यादा
पढ़ा सबसे ज्यादा इनको स्टडी किया यह कौन
थे ये एक प्रोफेसर थे यह एक प्रोफेसर थे
इन्होंने अपने स्टूडेंट्स को पढ़ाने के
लिए एक ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम बनाया था इन्होने
अपने स्टूडेंट को पढ़ाने के लिए ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम बनाया था जिसका नाम था
मिनिक्स एम आई एन आई एक्स जिसका नाम था
मिनिक्स ये इन्होंने बनाया था अब लिनिक्स
रवल ने क्या किया कि इस जो मिनिक्स
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है जो
एंड टेन बम ने बनाया था वो पूरा स्टडी
किया ठीक है उसी को पढ़ा और उसी के बेस पर
इन्होने क्या कर दिया अपना खुद का
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम बना डाला जिसका नाम
उन्होंने लिनक्स
रखा अब बहुत सारे लोगों को पता ठीक है यह
तो हिस्ट्री थी हमारी लिनक्स की कि लिनक्स
1991 में लिनक्स टर वर्ल्ड के द्वारा
बनाया गया बट क्या है कि वो कैसे बनाया
गया यह थोड़ी सी हिस्ट्री थी अब क्या है
कि बहुत से लोगों को पता है
कि नेक्स तो हमें पता ही है एक जीएन यू
सबद और सुना होगा कि जी एनय क्या चीज है
जी एन यू हैय जी एन यू अगर मैं आपको बताऊ
तो अब
1991 टू अब क्या हो रहा था कि
1991 टू
1995 के अंतर्वाल एक मूवमेंट चल रहा था
इसके अंदर एक मूवमेंट था जिसका नाम था
फ्री सॉफ्टवेयर मूमेंट जिसका नाम
था
फी सॉफ्टवेयर मूवमेंट
फी सॉफ्टवेयर मूवमेंट था अब इस मूवमेंट का
पर्पस क्या था कि उस टाइम पर क्या था कि
मैक्सिमम सॉफ्टवेयर पेड थे अब लोगों को
काम करना है डेवलपर को काम करना है कंपनी
को काम करना है ठीक है तो हर चीज तो पे
नहीं कर सकते ना तो उन्होंने क्या कि उस
टाइम प इस मूमेंट के दौरान क्या कि बहुत
सारे सॉफ्टवेयर्स को फ्री कर दिया गया
और इसलिए क्या कि बहुत सारे सॉफ्टवेयर को
फ्री कर दिया गया तो जी एनय का जो
प्रोजेक्ट था जो जी एनय जो मूवमेंट था
जीनय का नाम था उसमें क्या कर दिया इसलिए
जीन बोला जाता क्योंकि इसमें बहुत सारे
सॉफ्टवेयर्स को क्या कर दिया फ्री कर दिया
गया अब क्या है
कि हम क्या
उनको अगर हम मिक्स कर देते हैं तो हमारा
बनता है ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम जिसको हम बोलते
हैं ओस ठीक है लेकिन हमने क्या करते हम नस
को ही ओस बोलना शुरू करते लेकिन एक्चुअल
में ओस यह है नक्स एक कर्नल का नाम है ठीक
है अब मैं बताता हूं इसके भी कुछ फ्लेवर
इसके फ्लेवर्स आ ठीक है फ्लेवर्स ऑफ
लिनेक्स कौन
से फ्लेवर्स ऑफ लिनेक्स लेस के फ्लेवर्स
कौन से थे मैं आपको बताता हूं अब देखो
क्या है कि फेडोरा बेस्ड आ गया
बेस्ड ठीक है एक आ गया डेवियन
बेस्ड डेवियन बेस्ड ठीक है अब हो क्या फ
बेस में जैसे की आरल आ गया रेड इंटरप्राइज
लिनेक्स
सेंट ओस आ गया अब यह भी कंपनिया इन्होने
भी अपने क्या कर दिया वेंडर स्पेसिफिक
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम निकाल दिए उसके बाद डेन
में आ गया हमारा डेयन बेस में काली
लिनेक्स
ठीक है जो हम पढ़ने वाले हैं पैरेट
ओस ठीक है पट ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम उसके बाद आ
गया नटू ठीक है और भी बहुत सारे बच गए अब
जैसे कि अदर में बोलता हूं कि
एजन अजन नक् ठीक है यह भी है अब मिंट भी
हैसे बहुत सारे हैं तो अब यह सारे क्या है
फ्लेवर्स ऑफ लिनक्स है अब मैं बात करता
हूं कि यह ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम क्या होता है
नहीं पता है जिनको उनको पता चल जाए कि व्ट
इज एक
मिनट व्हाट इज ओस ये ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है
क्या ओस क्या होता है
कि यूजर्स एंड जो हार्डवेयर है यूजर्स एंड
हार्डवेयर के बीच का एक इंटरफेस है इनके
बीच का क्या है एक इंटरफेस है कैसे अगर
यूजर को अपने हार्डवेयर से कोई भी काम
करवाना है ठीक है अगर यूजर को अपना काम
करवाने के लिए हार्डवेयर को यूज करना है
तो उन्हें क्या कर पड़ेगी ओस की जरूरत
पड़ेगी अदर वाइज अगर ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम नहीं
होगा तो उसको एक छोटे से कट कॉपी पेस्ट
इवन माउस को भी मूवमेंट करवाने के लिए
बहुत सारे लाइंस ऑफ कोड लिखने पड़ेंगे जो
पॉसिबल नहीं है हर काम करने के लिए इसलिए
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम इनके बीच में एक इंटरफेस
का काम करता है अब क्या है ओस को एक्सेस
भी दो तरीके से किया जाता है इसको भी ओस
को एक्सेस टू दो तरीके से किया जाता है एक
तो सील आई जिसको बोलते हैं हम कमांड लाइन
इंटरफेस
कमांड लाइन
इंटरफेस एक एक होता है जीय आई जिसको हम
बोलते
हैं
ग्राफिकल यूजर इंटरफेस ग्राफिकल यूजर
इंटरफेस ग्राफिकल यूजर इंटरफेस अभी तक हम
क्या करते हैं विंडो यूज करते आ रहे हैं
ठीक है
कि हम जब सबसे ज्यादा क्या देखते आ रहे
हैं ग्राफिकल यूजर इंटरफेस एग्जांपल हमारा
कौन सा है
विंडो 10 या 11 ये क्या है जीय आई
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है ठीक है लेकिन जब विंडो
के अंदर आप कमांड प्रोमट का यूज करते हैं
सीएमडी यूज करते हैं सीएमडी ओपन करते हैं
तो क्या होता है वहां पर आपको क्या देखने
को मिलता है एक ब्लैक स्क्रीन देखने को
मिलती है जिसको हम बोलते हैं सीएल आई आप
चाहो तो विंडो में सीएल आई भी यूज कर सकते
हो एज पर यर रिक्वायरमेंट बट जो हमारा
लिनक्स ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है व पूरा का पूरा
सील आई बेस्ड है ग्राफिकल बेस भी है बट
उतना मजा नहीं आएगा ठीक है जितना विंडो
में आता है बट क्या कि अगर आप सील आई यूज
करोगे तो आपको बहुत ही ज्यादा बेहतरीन मजा
आने वाला उसमें क्योंकि विंडो से काफी
फास्ट होता है तो अब हम थोड़ा सा डिस्कस
करने वाले हैं फीचर्स ऑफ के बारे में
फीचर्स ऑफ नक्स
नक्
फीचर्स अब सबसे पहला फीचर्स तो क्या है यह
ओपन
सोर्स ओपन सोर्स है ओपन सोर्स का मतलब
मैंने बताया ऑलरेडी बता चुका हूं कि अभी
जस्ट एक मिनट दो मिनट पहले ही बताया कि
ओपन सोर्स का मतलब होता है जिसका सोर्स
कोड अवेलेबल है यह मतलब नहीं है कि फ्रीली
अवेलेबल है पेड अवेलेबल बट जिसका सोर्स
कोड अवेलेबल है अब क्या है कि बहुत सारे
आप लोगों में से सोच रहे होंगे कि हर कोई
तो विंडो सिस्टम यूज करता है इवन हम भी
मैं लाइव स्ट्रीम कर रहा हूं मैं भी विंडो
रेटिंग सिस्टम यूज कर रहा हूं आप लोग भी
विंडो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम से देख रहे हो और
इवन 90 पर लोग अभी भी ो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
यूज करते हैं एज अपने पर्सनल पीसी कुछ भी
बट कंपनिया नक् क्यों यूज करती है विंडो
की बजाय कंपनिया लिनस क यूज करती है जब
इतना अच्छा है सब कुछ यूज करने में यूजर
फ्रेंडली है तो
वई और कंपनिया लिनस को क्यों प्रेफर करती
है दूसरा सवाल यह आता है और तीसरा सवाल यह
है
कंपनिया लिनक्स एडमिन क्यों चाहिए फिर
उनको तो इन सबका जवाब यही इसी में छुपा
हुआ है ओपन सोर्स में ओपन सोर्स मतलब क्या
है कि देखो माइक्रोसॉफ्ट ने अपना ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम बनाया और उसने क्या की अपना ओएस
कोड था जो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम कोड था वह शेयर
करने से मना कर दिया अब विंडो को अगर
चलाना है आपको तो माइक्रोसॉफ्ट का लाइसेंस
चाहिए ठीक है विंडो क्योंकि
फ्री नहीं है लेकिन लिनक्स क्या है वो
क्या करता कि आप मेरा ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम यूज
करो मैं आपको सोर्स कोड भी दूंगा जैसे
आपको यूज करना है करो जैसे आपको
मॉडिफिकेशन करना है करो लेकिन विंडो का
ऐसा नहीं है अब बोलोगे कि सर हम तो बहुत
सारे लोग है कि हम पायलेटेड यूज करते हैं
हमें लाइसेंस की जरूरत नहीं है बट किसी एक
कंपनी में पायलेटेड विंडो यूज नहीं कर
सकते क्योंकि अगर पायरेटेड विंडो यूज हुई
क्योंकि विंडो पूरा ट्रैक करके रखता है कि
कौन पाय यूज कर रहा है कौन जेनन यूज कर
रहा है और उससे वो ट्रैक करके उस कंपनी को
खत्म कर देगा क्योंकि वो बोलेगा मेरा ही
यूज करना है अब विंडो क्या है कि दूसरा
कारण मैं बताता हूं कि क्यों यू कर
क्योंकि विंडोज बहुत महंगे हैं ठीक है
बहुत महंगे हैं मैं अब ऐसे तो पेड तो
[संगीत]
आपको जैसे यूज करना है हमारा यूज करो बाकी
मैं अपना सोर्स कोड प्रोवाइड नहीं करूंगा
हां आपको पॉलिसी इंप्लीमेंट करनी है कि
हां मैं बताऊंगा ऐसे ऐसे ये चीज यूज कर
सकते हो उसमें आप पॉलिसी डिफाइन कर सकते
हो बट मैं आपको अपना स कोड नहीं दूंगा
लिनक्स बोलता है कि मैं अपना दे दूंगा
दूसरा कारण क्या है कि यह सिक्योर है यह
सिक्योर है अब हर कोई बोलता है कि सिक्योर
है सिक्योर है सिक्योर है ये सिक्योर कैसे
है ठीक है सिक्योर कैसे है देखो क्या है
ना कि जब भी कोई भी मालवेयर हिट करता है
सबसे ज्यादा किसको हिट करता है विंडो को
लिनेस को बहुत कम करता है क्योंकि क्या
होता है कि हम सबको पता है कि जब भी कोई
मालवे या कोई भी हैकर एंटर करने की कोशिश
करेगा किसी भी मशीन के अंदर वो नेटवर्क के
थ्रू आएगा अब विंडो में क्या है कि एक बार
नेटवर्क के थ्रू एंटर कर गया तो क्या करता
है कि ठीक है एंटीवायरस उसको डिटेक्ट कर
पाए तो ठीक है अगर उसने अच्छी इ वेजन
टेक्निक का यूज किया हुआ है तो क्या करेगा
आपकी मशीन के अंदर एंटर कर जाएगा और आपकी
मशीन का पूरा कंट्रोल कर लेगा लेकिन
लिनिक्स में क्या है ओएस हार्ड निंग हो
रखी होती है और ओएस हार्ड निंग की वजह से
क्या होता है कि जिस भी डोमेन में जो भी
सर्विस रन कर रही होती है ठीक है और डोमेन
का मतलब क्या है कि जैसे आप वेब सर्वर
इसको यूज कर तो वेब सर्वर को एक्सेस करने
के लिए जिन जिन फाइल्स की जरूरत है सिर्फ
वो फाइल को उसमें क्या कर दिया डाल दिया
आपकी मशीन में ऑटोमेटिक क्या
एग्जीक्यूटेबल फाइल है वो क्या कर दिया
एग्जीक्यूट होगी बैकग्राउंड में और पूरी
मशीन को कंट्रोल कर लिया है लेकिन
दिस इ नॉट
पॉसिबल कक अगर वो रूट यूजर की परमिशन यूज
ही कर पा रहा तो इसका मतलब उसे जत नहीं है
फिर तो कुछ भी कंट्रोल कर लेगा बट क्या है
कि सिक्योरिटी के मामले इसलिए एडवांस है
क्योंकि वहा पर परमिशन नहीं है उसको एक
डोमेन में ही रन करना है तो दिस इ द मेन
रीजन नक्स इ द मोर सिक्योर देन विंडोज
एवरी एवरीथिंग क्योंकि इवन सबको पता होगा
कि जो हम एड यूज करते वो भी लिनेक्स बेस
है ठीक है तो अब बात करते हैं तीसरा पॉइंट
क्या है कि इसका तीसरा पॉइंट है कि इसको
अपडेट करना बहुत ही आसान है इजी टू अपडेट
इजी टू
अपडेट इजी टू अपडेट इसको अपडेट करना बहुत
आसान है इस चौथा पॉइंट क्या है यह लाइट
वेट है लाइट वेट लाइट वेट का मतलब क्या है
कि ओस का साइज बहुत कम है और यह कम रैम
कंजन करता है जब आप किसी भी पर्टिकुलर
क्या करो किसी भी अगर काली नेस को इंस्टॉल
करोगे आप इवन 1gb रम देते हो तो काफी बेटर
परफॉर्मेंस देता है आपके विंडो से विंडो
को 4gb रम दोगे तब भी हैंग करके चलता है
8gb चाहिए अच्छा नेटवर्क कनेक्टिविटी
चाहिए तब जाके विंडो अच्छे से रन करता है
बट
जो आपको अभी समझनी जरूरी है अब थोड़ा सा
कंपेयर करके दिखाता हूं
आपको कंपेयर इन द स की वैसे कंपेरिजन
विंडोज
जो सबसे मेन यूजर सुपर यूजर उसको बोलते
हैं हम
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर और नक् में उसको हम बोलते
हैं रूट यूजर उसको बोलते हैं रूट यूजर अब
उसके बाद जो फाइल होती है विंडो में फाइल
को हम फाइल ही बोलते हैं नक् में और
सॉफ्टवेयर को जो सॉफ्टवेयर होते हैं हमारे
विंडो के अंदर जिनको हम सॉफ्टवेयर बोलते
हैं लिनक्स में हम उनको बोलते हैं
पैकेज प ए सी के ए जी ए उनको बोलते हैं हम
पैकेजेस
अब मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं कि अब हम ने की
जो डाटा स्टोरेज प्लानिंग होती है कैसे
होती
है क्या होता है कि जब भी हम अपनी मशीन
में न का इंस्टॉलेशन करते हैं तो लिनक्स
में दो टाइप का डाटा आपको देखने को
मिलेंगे ठीक है नक्स में दो टाइप का डाटा
कौन कन
सा लिनक्स है एक तो मिलेगा उसमें ओस
डिफाइन डाटा
ओस डिफाइंड डटा दूसरा आपको देखने को मिलता
है
यूजर डिफाइंड डाटा यूजर डिफाइंड
डाटा अब इसकी प्लानिंग कैसे होती है यह
डाटा कैसे डिसाइड कैसे प्लान हुआ उसके
बारे में बताता हूं उससे पहले मैं थोड़ा
सा आपको एग्जांपल लूंगा मैं कंपेयर करने
वाला हूं विंडो के साथ विंडो के साथ
कंपेयर करने वाला हूं आपके लिनक्स
की जो विंडोज ओस है ठीक है अब क्या होता
है कि जब भी हम अपनी मशीन में क्या करते
हैं विंडो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम इंस्टॉल करते
हैं तो क्या होता है कि बाय डिफॉल्ट आपको
क्या देखने को मिलता है आपकी मशीन में एक
तो सी ड्राइव देखने को मिलती है एक डी
ड्राइव देखने को मिलती है एक ई ड्राइव अगर
हमने क्रिएट की हुई है तो हम ई ड्राइव
हमें देखने को मिलती है अब जब भी हम सी
ड्राइव को ओपन करते हैं तो सी ड्राइव में
हमें क्या देखने को मिलता है बहुत सारी
फोल्डर्स बहुत सारी फाइल्स बहुत सारे
प्रोग्राम्स आपको बाय डिफॉल्ट उसमें देखने
को मिलते हैं अब जो यह फोल्डर्स फाइल्स है
जो प्रोग्राम आपको देखने को मिलते हैं सी
ड्राइव के अंदर उसको हम बोलते हैं ओस
डिफाइंड डाटा ठीक है इसको हम बोलते हैं ओस
डिफाइंड डाटा और जो यह बच गया हमारा सी
ड्राइव डी ड्राइव इसको हम यूज करते हैं
पर्सनल डाटा के लिए ठीक है उसको यूज करते
पर्सनल डाटा के लिए अपने मूवी स्टोर कर
लिया फोटोस डॉक्यूमेंट एट और इसको हम
बोलते हैं बोले यूजर डिफाइन डाटा यूजर
डिफाइन डाटा मतलब जो डाटा यूजर के द्वारा
डिफाइंड किया गया है क्रिएट किया गया है
अब यह देखो ओस डिफाइन डाटा क्या है जो बाय
डिफॉल्ट ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम जब भी इंस्टॉल
होता आपकी मशीन के अंदर वो क्रिएट हो जाता
है अब ऐसा नहीं है कि ओस डिफाइन जो डाटा
है व ओनली ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम इंस्टॉल होते
वक्त ही क्रिएट होता है नहीं यह भी दो
तरीके से होता है ठीक है
डिफाइन
ओस डिफाइंड डाटा ठीक है यह भी दो टाइप से
फर्स्ट फर्स्ट तो एक तो ड्यूरिंग
इंस्टॉलेशन
ड्यूरिंग इंस्टॉलेशन ठीक है जब भी आपका
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम इंस्टॉल होता है तो उसके
साथ जो भी फाइल्स जो भी प्रोग्राम्स बाय
डिफॉल्ट जनरेट होते हैं आपकी मशीन में तो
वह क्या होते हैं
आपके एक तो इस तरीके से आपका ओ डिफाइन
डाटा क्रिएट होता है दूसरा क्या होता है
कि जब भी आपका ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम इंस्टॉल हो
गया
आफ्टर
इंस्टॉलेशन इंस्टॉलेशन ऑफ ओस इसके बाद
क्या होता है कि जब भी आप क्या करते हैं
कोई भी सॉफ्टवेयर हम क्या करते हैं कोई
भी सॉफ्टवेयर या एप्लीकेशन हमारी मशीन में
इंस्टॉल करते हैं तो क्या होता है कि उसके
साथ भी बहुत सारे प्रोग्राम्स होते हैं
बहुत सारी उसकी फाइल्स होती है वह बाय
डिफॉल्ट क्या होती है आपकी सी ड्राइव के
अंदर जाकर स्टोर हो जाती है और जो सी
ड्राइव के अंदर स्टोर हो जाती है तो यह भी
एक दूसरा तरीका है कि यूजर डिफाइन डटा
आपका तो इन दो तरी से आपका जो है जो ओएस
डिफाइन डाटा है वो आपको यहां पर देखने को
मिलता है इन दो तरीके से अब जो यूजर
डिफाइन डाटा है उसके बाद करता हूं जो यूजर
डिफाइंड डाटा है
हमारा
यूजर डिफाइंड
डाटा यूजर डिफाइन डाटा हमेशा क्या होता है
कि जब भी आपका ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम इंस्टॉल
होगा उसके बाद जो भी फाइल्स डायरेक्टरी भी
क्रिएट करोगे या जो भी आप मूवी स्टोर को
जो भी करोगे वह उसके बाद ही क्रिएट होता
है चलो थोड़ा सा इसके बारे में डाटा के
बारे में थोड़ा सा डिस्कस करते हैं थोड़ा
सा डिटेल में जाते हैं अब डेटा डटा
बेसिकली क्या होता है कि इंफॉर्मेशन डटा
कुछ कुड बी एनीथिंग कुछ भी हो सकता है ठीक
डटा का मतलब यह होता है अब बात करते हैं
हम टाइप्स ऑफ डाटा के बारे में इसके बारे
में हम बात करते
हैं टाइप्स ऑफ डाटा टा के दो टाइप होते
हैं एक तो होता आपका डिफॉल्ट डाटा
डिफॉल्ट डाटा आपको देखने को मिलता है
दूसरा होता है आपका कस्टमाइज
डाटा कस्टमाइज्ड
डाटा ठीक है अब जो डिफॉल्ट डाटा है एक
प्रकार से इसको आप क्या बोल दो ओस डिफाइन
डाटा हम एक प्रकार से इसको बोल सकते हैं
ओस डिफाइंड डाटा क्यों क्योंकि जब भी
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम इंस्टॉल हुआ या ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम इंस्टॉल होने के बाद हमने जिस भी
फाइल जिस भी एप्लीकेशन या सॉफ्टवेयर को
डाउनलोड किया इंस्टॉल किया तो उसके साथ
जितने भी बाय डिफॉल्ट फाइल्स क्रिएट हुई
वह आपकी सी ड्राइव के अंदर या डिफॉल्ट
डाटा के अंदर जाकर स्टोर हो जाती है ठीक
है अब उसके बाद कस्टमाइज डाटा को हम क्या
बोल सकता हूं यूजर डिफाइंड डाटा भी बोल
सकता हूं मतलब यूजर डिफाइंड डाटा कस्टमर
डाटा के अंदर में इसको क्या कर लेता
हूं
यूजर डिफाइंड डाटा इसको मैं कस्टमर डाटा
के अंडर ले लेता हूं क्योंकि जब भी आफ्टर
द ओस इंस्टॉलेशन मतलब जब हमारा ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम इंस्टॉल हो गया उसके बाद जो भी
किसी भी यूजर के द्वारा कोई भी काम किया
गया कोई भी फाइल डॉक्यूमेंट कुछ भी काम
किया गया वह आ गया आपका कस्टमाइज डाटा के
अंदर अब हमें पता चल गया बेसिकली मेरा
मोटो क्या था बताने का विंडो में कि जब भी
हम विंडो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम इंस्टॉल करते
हैं बाय डिफॉल्ट सी ड्राइव में उसके बहुत
सारे फोल्डर्स आपको देखने को मिलते हैं
बहुत सारी फाइल्स आपको देखने को मिलती है
बाय डिफॉल्ट यही सेम फंडा आपको न में भी
देखने को मिलता है बट क्या होता है कि
लिनक्स के केस में सी ड्राइव डी ड्राइव ई
ड्राइव नहीं होते ठीक है ड्राइव डी ड्राइव
नहीं होती लेकिन लिनक्स में इन ड्राइव का
कोई कांसेप्ट ही नहीं है बट लि का क्या
कांसेप्ट है व उसके बारे में बताने वाला
हूं नेक्स में जितना भी डाटा स्टोर होता
है वह एक पेरेंट फोल्डर के अंदर जा स्टोर
होता है करेंट ठीक है अगर आप लोगों को
नहीं पता न के केस में तो जो लिनक्स होता
उसका सारा का सारा डाटा एक पैरेंट फोल्डर
बोल सकते हैं हम इसको पी ए आर ई एन टी
पैरेंट फोल्डर अगर मैं आपको सिंबल दिखाऊं
इसका तो सिंबल है इसका
ये य आप सबको दिखाई दे रहा है ये रहा यह
वो है जिसके अंदर सारा का सारा डाटा जिसके
अंडर सारे के सारे क्या है फाइल्स या जो
भी आपका ओस डिफाइन डाटा है या जोट होता है
तो अब ओ डिफाइन डाटा हो या यूजर डिफाइन
डाटा हो वो सारा का सारा डाटा
इसके नीचे क्रिएट होता है सारा डाटा इसके
नीचे ही क्रिएट होना
है
ओस डिफाइन डाटा भी
और यूजर डिफाइंड डाटा भी ठीक है वो सारा
सारा इसी के अंडर क्रिट होना है इसमें सी
ड्रा डी ड्रा का कोई कांसेप्ट नहीं है अब
हम इसको क्या बोलते हैं जो आपको सिंबल
दिखाई दे रहा है आपका बैकवर्ड जिसको हम
बोलते हैं फॉरवर्ड स्लैश इसको हम बोल सकते
हैं रूट पार्टीशन
प ए आर टी आ इसको हम रूट पार्टीशन भी बोल
सकते हैं या इसको हम पैरेंट पार्टीशन भी
बोल सकते हैं पी ए आर ई एनटी पेरेंट
पार्टीशन भी बोल सकते हैं और या इसको हम
बोल सकते हैं पैरेंट फोल्डर पी ए आर
पैरेंट फोल्डर बट आपको मैं एक चीज बताऊ
क्लेडी के लिए सबसे ज्यादा आपको देखने को
यूज करने को मिलेगा हम या तो इसको रूट
पार्टीशन बोलेंगे ठीक है या पैरेंट
पार्टीशन ठीक है क्योंकि बाकी टर्म्स में
आप कंफ्यूज हो जाओगे बाद में जब भी कर रहे
होगे पूरे कोर्स में क्या बोले ये क्या
चीज होती है इसमें कंफ्यूजन हो तो बेटर
ऑप्शन है कि आप अपने ध्यान में रखो याद
रखो कि इसको हम बोल सकते हैं रूट
पार्टन अब क्या है कि जब भी आप क्या करते
हो जैसे कि आप विंडो में जाते हो माय
कंप्यूटर क्लिक करते हो तो वहां पर क्या
हैगा आपकी फाइल खुल जाती है लोकल डि सीडी
अब
फॉरवर्ड स्लैश आपको देखने को मिलेगा ये
फॉरवर्ड स्लैश आपको देखने को मिलेगा तो
समझ लो कि
अब बात करते हैं
कि इसके अंदर दो दो टाइप्स का डाटा है य
कैसे किस टाइप से होता है ठीक यह दो टाइप
का डाटा है यह इसके बारे में बात करते
हैं अब इसके बारे में समझने से पहले मैं
थोड़ा सा बताता हूं आपको अब मैं एक चीज
ध्यान रखना कि जब भी हमारा नक् इंस्टॉल
हुआ जब भी
हमारा
मिनट जब भी हमारा नक्स इंस्टॉल
हुआ क्या हुआ उसमें बाय डिफॉल्ट
आपको
बाय
डिफॉल्ट क्या होता है कि
अराउंड 19 सब डायरेक्टर क्रेट हो जाती है
सब डायरेक्टरी क्रिएट हो जाती है यह 17 भी
हो सकती है 16 भी हो सकती है य डिपेंड्स
ऑन द ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम ठीक है 17 15 20 कुछ
भी हो सकती है ये फिक्स नहीं है बट मैं
एग्जांपल लेके चल रहा हूं कि अभी हमारी
मशीन में 19 सबडायरेक्टरी है फॉर एग्जांपल
ठीक है लेकिन बाय डिफॉल्ट क्या है कि ये
ही अराउंड रता है 16 17 18 19 इतनी ही
सबडायरेक्टरी बाय डिफॉल्ट क्रिएट हो जाती
है ऑटोमेटिक जब भी आपका ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
इंस्टॉल होता है अब क्या है ये डायरेक्टरी
अब हर एक डायरेक्टरी क्या है ना अपना-अपना
काम है ठीक है हर एक डायरेक्टरी के लिए जो
19 डायरेक्टरीज है उनके अपने-अपने रूल
डिफाइंड है ठीक है और पूरा का पूरा
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
इन्हीं 19 डायरेक्टरीज पर क्या करता है
डिपेंड करता है ठीक है अब इसमें क्या है
ना इस ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम में इस 19
डायरेक्टरी में पहले से ही सेट है कि किस
डायरेक्टरी में या किस फोल्डर में उसकी
कन्फेशन फाइल सेव होंगी किसम उसके
टेंपरेरी फाइल सेव होंगी किसम उसकी
प्रोसेस की फाइल सेव होंगी किसम उसकी
लाइब्रेरी फाइल सेव होंगी और किसम उसकी
लॉग फाइल सेव होगी ये लिनक्स में पहले से
ही सेट है यह आपको इस पर चिंता करने की
जरूरत नहीं है क्योंकि ये पहले से ही
डिफाइंड है यह चेंज नहीं होता इन 19 सब
डायरेक्टरीज के अंदर ही है पहले से ही
पहले और इन्हीं पर एज पर डिफाइंड परमिशन
के हिसाब से ही आपको काम करना होता है अब
आप सोच रहे होगी कि अगर मैं कोई भी फाइल
क्रिएट करता हूं या मैंने क्या किया एक और
फोल्डर क्रिएट किया या एक और डायरेक्टरी
क्रिएट की सब डायरेक्टरी तो क्या वो 19 के
अंदर आएगी या अलग से तो वह 19 के अलावा
जाएगी 20 21 ऐसे काउंट होने लग
जाएगा अब मैंने बताया कि जब भी ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम इंस्टॉल हुआ तो 19 सब डायरेक्टरी
क्रिएट हुई अब अगला सवाल आपका यह होगा कि
फिर यूजर कहां से ऑपरेट करते हैं इसम
इसमें यूजर कहां से ऑपरेट करेंगे क्योंकि
आपने बताया कि बाय डिफॉल्ट 19 डायरेक्ट
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के साथ इल यूर कहां से
रेट करेंगे तो थोड़ा सा इसके बारे में
एक्सप्लेन कर देता हूं 19 डायरेक्ट के
बारे में वो क्या है देखो ये सारी की सारी
19 डायरेक्टरी आपके रूट पार्टीशन के अंदर
आती है ठीक है मैंने लिया यहां पर
अराउंड 19
डिफॉल्ट
डायरेक्टरीज अब इसमें से क्या होता है
इसमें
से क्या
होगा मैं आपको ऐसे इसलिए कर रहा हूं सो
दैट कि आप इसको फॉरवर्ड सेल्स को
आईडेंटिफाई करो लेकिन ये आपकी कली ब्रैकेट
में नहीं आता तो इसमें से क्या होता है कि
जो
अराउंड जो 17 डायरेक्टरीज है जो 17
डायरेक्टरीज है उनको क्या करता है उनको
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम ऑपरेट करता
है जो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के द्वारा क्या की
जाती है ऑपरेट की जाती है अब बच गई जो दो
डायरेक्टरी एग्जांपल दिया जो आप बच गी दो
डायरेक्टरीज इन दो डायरेक्टरीज में क्या
है
कि जो एक
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री सुपर यूजर की होम
डायरेक्टरी है उसको हम बोल सकते हैं होम
डायरेक्टरी ऑफ रूट यूजर और सुपर यूजर और
जो दूसरी बच गी एक
डायरेक्टरी ठीक है यह आपके नॉर्मल यूजर्स
के लिए यह आपके सारे के सारे जो नॉर्मल
यूजर्स है उनके लिए यह रिजर्व्ड है अब जो
मैंने बताया कि एक डायरेक्टरी रूट के होम
अकाउंट के लिए यूज होगी और जो दूसरी
डायरेक्टरी है इसमें नॉर्मल यूजर कितने भी
यूजर क्रिएट हो मशीन में 8 10 15 सारे के
सारे उस इसी डायरेक्टरी के अंदर आएंगे अब
यहां पर कंडीशन यह है कि एक यूजर किसी
दूसरे यूजर की होम अकाउंट में जाकर उसके
डाटा को चेक नहीं कर सकता कि दूसरे यूजर
ने अपने अकाउंट में क्या क्रिएट किया हुआ
है मतलब सीधी सी कहने की बात है कि एक
आदमी दूसरे घर के घर में जाकर झाग नहीं
सकता कि व अपने घर में क्या कर रहा है
सीधी सी सीधा सा मतलब यह
है स सा मतलब इसका ये है अब मैं बताता हूं
कि आपको डाटा क्रिएट जब भी हम डाटा क्रिएट
करेंगे हमारी नक्स मशीन के अंदर ठीक है तो
हमें यहां पर कुछ चीजों को ध्यान रखना
होता है यही वो चीजें है जहां पर गलतियां
होती है ठीक है अब एक चीज बताता हूं कि
बाय डिफॉल्ट जो रूट यूजर्स है या आपका जो
सुपर यूजर है वह कहीं भी डायरेक्टरी कोई
भी डायरेक्टरी कोई भी फाइल्स क्रिएट कर
सकता है मशीन में कहीं पर भी और किसी भी
जगह पर ठीक है मैं यहां पर लिखूं अगर आपको
लिखता
हूं बाय डिफॉल्ट
बाय
डिफॉल्ट आवर रूट
यूजर आवर ट यूजर
कैन
क्रिएट फाइल्स
और
डायरेक्टरी ऑन
एनी प्लेस ठीक है अब वो किसी भी जगह पर
क्या कर सकता है क्रिएट कर सकता है ली बात
है अब मैंने एक टम य पर यूज की है प्लेस
ठीक
है इसका क्या मतलब है ठीक है ये दो टाइप्स
का होता है होता है आपका दो टाइप्स
का पहला जो पहला होता है आपका एक तो
बोलेंगे हम प्राइवेट प्लेस सबका होता है
इनका भी प्राइवेट प्लेस दूसरा पब्लिक
प्लेस
पब्लिक प्लेस अब प्राइवेट और पब्लिक से
मतलब क्या है ठीक है
इनसे मतलब
है चाहे आप रूट यूजर
हो चाहे
आप नॉर्मल यूजर
हो आप दोनों के जो होम अकाउंट
है वह आपके प्राइवेट प्लेस के अंदर आते
हैं मतलब क्या है कि सीधी सी बतला है
कि एवरी यूजर
हैव डिफॉल्ट
राइट डिफॉल्ट राइट
ऑफ डाटा
क्रिएशन
इन देयर
होम डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
यूजर को बाय डिफॉल्ट अपने प्राइवेट पलेस
में कुछ भी करने की परमिशन है और चाहे व
फाइल क्रिएट करे फाइल डिलीट करे फ
एग्जीक्यूट करे कुछ भी ठीक है बाय डिफ
नॉर्मल यूजर भी अब
उनके होम डायरेक्टरी को छोड़कर होम अकाउंट
को छोड़कर जितने भी प्लेसेस बच गए जितनी
भी जगह बच वो सारे के सारे पब्लिक प्लेस
में काउंट होते हैं ठीक है व के सारे क्या
हो उसके पब्लिक प्लेस में काउंट होते
हैं
एक्सेप्ट
यूजर्स होम
डायरेक्टरी यूजर्स की होम डायरेक्टरी को
छोड़ के होल्स
आर पब्लिक
प्लेस पब्लिक सारे के सारे क्या आपके
पब्लिक प्लेस है तो मैंने बताया कि य पर
दो पब्लिक और प्राइवेट हो ग अब कुछ लोग
बोलेंगे कि सर क्या मैं रूट यूजर हूं तो
फिर मेरे लिए भी क्या ये पब्लिक प्राइवेट
कुछ मायने रखता है तो बताइए घर आपका है यह
घर आपने घर बना आप ही नेय पार्टीशन किया
हुआ है आप तो आप तो कहीं भी आ जा सकते हो
ना आपके लिए पब्लिक प्राइवेट नहीं है ना
ठीक है बट क्या है कि एक टर्मिनोलॉजी के
हिसाब से पब्लिक और प्राइवेट इसलिए डिफाइन
किया है अगर आपको कहीं भी चलो आप एक अटैकर
हो आप एथिकल हैकर हो
नो इशू तो आप रूट भी बन सकते हो और आप
अपनी मशीन में नर्मल ज बन सकते हो इन द
सेंस अगर आप क्या करोगे जब आप लिनेक्स
प्रशन कर रहे होगे कुछ भी कर रहे होगे तो
आपको या इवन कोई भी लिनक्स एडमिन होता हो
उसको किसी भी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के अंदर क्या
होता है कि रूट एक्सेस नहीं होता रूट
एक्सेस दिया ही नहीं जाता नॉर्मल यूजर
रहता है वो तो हम है कि हम अपनी मशीन में
हमेशा हमें आदत पड़ गई है कि हम अपनी मशीन
में एज रूट यूजर काम करते हैं दिस इ बैड
थिंग कभी किसी दिन कोई अटैकर आया और आपकी
मशीन में घुस गया तो घुस गया रूट यूजर
नहीं बना जब तक जुरत ना हो तब तक रूट यूजर
मत बनो सुडो से काम चला लो अब सुडो क्या
होता है मैं बताऊंगा बट क्या कि तब तक जब
तक जरूरत ना हो तब तक मत बनो ठीक है
क्योंकि आप की सिक्योरिटी को इशू है इसमें
ठीक है जो भी सिस्टम सिक्योरिटी है तो अब
मैंने यहां पर ये बता दिया पब्लिक और
प्राइवेट का
पंधा क्योंकि सुपर यूजर कहीं भी कुछ भी कर
सकता है ठीक है और नर्मल यूजर क्या कर
सकता है वो सिर्फ अपने होम अकाउंट के अंदर
कुछ भी कर सकता है लेकिन एक चीज ध्यान
रखना यहां पर यह रूल सबके लिए हैं अब उसके
अलावा से नॉर्मल यूजर काम करे पब्लिक
प्लेस में या रूट यूजर काम करे अब रूट
तोलो चाहे तो बदल सकता है लेकिन नर्मल र
नहीं बदल सकता लेकिन अगर पब्लिक प्लेस में
कोई भी फाइल आपको क्रिएट करनी है कोई भी
डायरेक्टरी क्रिएट करनी है या किसी भी
फाइल के साथ आपको काम करना है तो क्या है
आपको जो परमिशन
पहले से ही जो परमिशन सेट है ठीक है
उन्हीं के हिसाब से काम करना होगा नक्स
में ठीक है उन्हीं के हिसाब हिब से काम
करना होगा लिनक्स के अंदर ठीक है अब जस्ट
जस्ट मिनट ठीक है तो उसी के हिसाब से आपको
काम करना
होगा तो अब मैंने बता दिया पब्लिक और
प्राइवेट क्योंकि
तो य यह थी व सबसे बड़ी बात कि जो लोगों
के साथ प्रॉब्लम होती थी कि जब भी हम क्या
करते थे कि अपनी मशीन के अंदर काम करते थे
या कोई भी साइबर सिक्योरिटी इंजीनियर अपनी
मशीन के अंदर काम करता था तो प्रॉब्लम यह
होती थी
कि वह कहीं भी कोई भी फाइल क्रिएट कर लेता
था कोई भी फाइल कहीं भी क्रिएट करने के
बाद व उसके बाद सोचता यार यहां पर मुझे
परमिशन क्यों नहीं मिल रही क्योंकि किसी
भी बिगनर या इवन इंटरमीडिएट लेवल भी यह
नहीं पता होता कि इसके अंदर हमें काम कहां
करना है जब मैं आपको फाइल सिस्टम पढ़ाऊंगा
तो उसके बाद आपको पता चल जाएगा कि हर एक
जो डायरेक्टरी है 19 या 17 जो भी
डायरेक्टरीज होंगी आपकी ठीक है तो
व
आपका उसका किस डायरेक्टरी में क्या होता
है वहां पर काम करने में आपको मजा आएगा तो
दिस इज द कांसेप्ट ऑफ स्टोरेज मैनेजमेंट
आई होप सबको समझ में आया होगा कि पब्लिक
प्राइवेट प्लेस क्या होता है प्राइवेट
प्लेस क्या होता है यह सारी चीजें है
क्योंकि अगर आपने यह सारी चीजें आज अगर
जान ली
तो कल का जो सेशन रहेगा मतलब नेक्स्ट जो
आपका शेड्यूल रहेगा सेशन तो उसमें आप जब
पढ़ोगे या आज के बाद जो भी आप पढ़ने वाले
हो ठीक है जो भी आप लिनक्स में काम करोगे
तो आपको कभी भी यह डाउट नहीं आएगा मुझे
कहां पर फाइल क्रिएट करनी है कहां पर नहीं
करनी कहां पर क्या काम करना है कहां पर
क्या नहीं ठीक है तो यह बेसिक स्टोरेज
मैनेजमेंट का आपका मैंने आपको बता दिया कि
नक् में कैसे स्टोरेज को मैनेज किया जाता
है तो अभी मैं आपको क्या कि मशीन पर लेकर
जाके दिखाता हूं कुछ
चीजें ू
मशीन ठीक है अभी आपको हमारी स्क्रीन पर
देखने को मिल रही होगी यह हमारी नक्स मशीन
है यह हमारी न की मशीन है जिसको काली
नेक्स बोला जाता है जो काली ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम है जनरली व पेंटेस्टर के द्वारा
यूज किया जाता है सिक्योरिटी प्रोफेशनल के
द्वारा यूज किता जबसे मोस्ट पॉपुलर
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है जब आप क्या करते हो जब
काली नेक्स को यूज करते हो ठीक है पैरेट
और काली सबसे ज्यादा आपको सुनने को मिलते
है और उन्हें भी सबसे ज्यादा आप काली को
यूज करते हो ये बेसिक ओवरव्यू यह आपका
टर्मिनल है ठीक है जब भी आप जिस पर भी काम
करते हो यह है आपका
टर्मिनल जिसके ऊपर आप काम करते हो अब मैं
आपको दिखा देता हूं बेसिक ओव्यू आपकी ये
आपका इसके अंदर क्या है कि ग्राफिकल व्यू
दिखा तो बहुत सारी एप्लीकेशन मोर देन 600
एली बाय डिफॉल्ट इसमें पैकेज इंस्टॉल होते
हैं तो हर एक चीज के हिसाब से कि
इंफॉर्मेशन गद के वनटी एनालिसिस के वेब
एप्लीकेशन एनालिसिस डाटाबेस असेसमेंट के
पासवर्ड अटैक्स मतलब बहुत सारे बाय
डिफॉल्ट पहले से ही है इसमें इंस्टॉल्ड है
पैकेजेस तो ये इसका आपको जीआई मोड दिखाई
दे रहा होगा यहां पर ठीक है आप सिंपली
किसी पर क्लिक करोगे तो वह काम करना शुरू
कर देगा बट हम क्या है कि जीआई यूज नहीं
करेंगे क्
यूजर के और आपके ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के बीच
में काम करता है ठीक है यह उन क्योंकि
मैंने आपको एक छोटी सी चीज बताई कि स क्या
होता है लेकिन एक्चुअल में देखोगे तो क्या
होता है कि अगर आर्किटेक्चर की बात करूं
तो सबसे पहले आपका क्या होता है हार्डवेयर
होता है हार्डवेयर के ऊपर कर्नल होता है
जिसको हम लिनेक्स बोलते हैं उसके ऊपर आपका
सेल होता है और उसके ऊपर क्या करते हैं
यूजर्स काम करते हैं अब यूजर्स को कुछ भी
काम करवाना हार्डवेयर से तो वह क्या करता
है यह जो आपका टर्मिनल है जिसम अभी आप ये
ओपन हो जाएगा यह रहा यह टर्मिनल है एक सेल
खुल गया ठीक है तो हम सिंपली इस परे कमांड
फायर करते हैं कुछ भी लिखते हैं तो यह
क्या करता है यह सीधा ले जाके आपके कर्नल
को दे देता है और कर्नल क्या हार्डवेयर को
प्रोवाइड कर देता है हार्डवेयर प कमांड
फायर करने के लिए कि जो भी हमें आउटपुट
चाहिए होता जो भी काम करना होता है उसके
बाद क्या मिलता है हमें आ अपनी स्क्रीन पर
आउटपुट मिल जाता है फ कर्नल फे सेम
प्रोसेस है कि कर्नल सेल को देता है सेड
यूजर को देता है ये सिंपल बेसिक
आर्किटेक्चर होती है अभी मैं आपको एक चीज
दिखा देता हूं कि अगर आप नेक्स्ट क्लास
है ओके तो ठीक है तो पब्लिक और प्राइवेट
में थोड़ा सा डिफरेंस के लिए आप लोग बोल
रहे हो तो मैं आपको बता देता हूं पब्लिक
और प्राइवेट देखो प्राइवेट आप समझिए कि
प्राइवेट क्या होता है आपकी पर्सनल लाइफ
में भी आप प्राइवेसी मेंटेन मतलब की
जिसमें सिर्फ आप ही मालिक हो आप ही ओनर हो
पब्लिक प्राइवेट का मैं आपको बता देता हूं
देख ये रहा कि जो भी आपका होम अकाउंट होता
है ठीक है स्लश होम यूजर मगर अभी आपको
दिखाता सीडी ये आपका रूट पार्टीशन में मैं
गया अभी दिखाता हूं आपको ये क्या चीज होती
है अब यहां पर आपको एक चीज दिखाई दे रही
होगी ये जिन मैं 19 सॉफ्टवेयर की बात कर
रहा हूं जिन मैं 17 या अराउंड की बात कर
रहा हूं ये कितने काउंट कर सकते हैं ये 17
18 होंगे जो ये आपका होता है होम ये रहा
ठीक है यह आपका होम होता है और यह कौन सा
है यह आपका जितने भी नॉर्मल यूजर्स होते
हैं सुपर यूजर्स के अलावा एक ये है रूट ये
रूट का का होम अकाउंट है ठीक है यह रूट का
होम अकाउंट है और यह है यूजर्स का होम
अकाउंट है इनके अलावा ये जितने भी आपको
डायरेक्टरीज या फाइल्स आपको देखने को मिल
रही हैं स्क्रीन के ऊपर यह सारे के सारे
पब्लिक प्लेस है और यह प्राइवेट प्लेस है
यह रूट का अपना प्राइवेट प्लेस है और यह
सारे जो यूजर्स है ठीक है यह सारे के सारे
जो यूजर्स नॉर्मल यूजर्स है नॉर्मल यूजर
कौन सा होता है जो एडमिन नहीं है इसका
जिसको बिल्कुल ही लिमिटेड परमिशन डिफाइंड
है वो होता है नॉर्मल यूजर और वह सारे के
सारे इसके अंदर होते हैं और इन दो जगह को
छोड़कर सारा का सारा क्या है आपका नक् में
पब्लिक प्लेस है मतलब वहां पर पहले से ही
हर डायरेक्टरी प कोई ना कोई परमिशन
डिफाइंड है
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री अगर आप अपने प्राइवेट
अकाउंट के अलावा आप प्राइवेट प्लेस के
अलावा अगर आप काम कर रहे हो तो क्या है कि
आपको पब्लिक में बाय डिफॉल्ट जो परमिशन है
उन्हीं के हिसाब से काम करना होगा ठीक है
वहां पर उनकी परमिशन के साथ आप छेड़छाड़
नहीं कर सकते अब जैसे कि आप अपने होम
अकाउंट में जो ये है मैं आपको हाईलाइट कर
रहा हूं इसके अंदर आप कुछ भी काम करो कोई
भी फाइल क्रिएट करो कोई भी डायरेक्टरी
क्रिएट करो कोई भी फाइल कुछ भी एग्जीक्यूट
करो या डिलीट करो कर सकते हो इसमें आपके
ऊपर कोई भी रिस्ट्रिक्शंस नहीं है अदर देन
इसके आपको रिस्ट्रिक्शंस है तो दिस इज द
डिफरेंस बिटवीन पब्लिक प्लेस एंड प्राइवेट
प्लेस ठीक है प्राइवेट का मतलब आप उसमें
कुछ भी कर सकते हो आप ठीक है उसके अलावा
आपके घर के अलावा जितने भी दूसरे घर बच गए
ठीक है पड़ोस में जो भी वो सब आपके लिए
क्या है पब्लिक है ठीक है लेकिन आपके लिए
प्राइवेट प्रॉपर्टी यही है इसके अलावा
प्राइवेट में क्या है कुछ भी कर सकते हो
लेकिन आप एक बात बताइए मैं एग्जांपल लिया
कि आप
एक सोसाइटी में रहते हैं सोसाइटी में क्या
होता है कि मैंने माना कि 50 घर है 50 घर
में से उनमें से आपका एक फ्लैट होगा आपका
घर होगा उस घर में क्या है कि आप उसके ओनर
हो उसके मालिक हो व आपका प्राइवेट प्लेस
है उसमें आप चाहे डांस करो म्यूजिक सुनो
कुछ भी करो क्या आप यह सारी चीजें किसी
दूसरे घर में जाकर कर सकते हो नहीं
क्योंकि पब्लिक प्रॉपर्टी है पब्लिक प्लेस
है अब यहां पर उस पब्लिक प्लेस की बात
नहीं हो रही कि मैं गया कि मैं अपने घर
में कुछ नहीं करूंगा और बाहर जाकर सब कुछ
करूंगा उसकी बात नहीं हो रही यहां पर वो
प्राइवेट प्रेस है अपने घर में आप कुछ भी
कर सकते हो दूसरे घर में जाकर आप नहीं कर
सकते क् उसको ट्रेस पास समझेगा मतलब कोई
मेरे घर में चोरी करने आया है ठीक है आप
किसी के घर में क्या है जाओगे बोला ठीक है
मैं बस घूम के आ सकते हो ज्यादा कुछ कर
सकते हो नहीं क्योंकि वहां पर उन्हीं के
हिसाब से काम होगा जो घर के ओनर है तो आई
होप कि इससे बेस्ट एग्जांपल नहीं
होगा तो अब जितने भी आपको डाउट्स आएंगे बी
पेशेंट विद मी मतलब मेरे साथ रहिए और
प्लीज कमेंट करते हुए नो इशू हम पढ़ेंगे
आपका डाउट क्लियर जो लेकिन मैं एक चीज
आपको बोलता हूं कि मैं जब भी पढ़ाता हूं
ना कि आप डाउट अपने पास रखिए लेकिन एक बार
मेरे कोर्सेस पूरा देखिए मतलब कि आज का
मैंने करवा दिया कल का एक टॉपिक लेकर
आऊंगा नेक्स्ट डे अलग टॉपिक ले आऊंगा अगर
उसके बाद भी आपके जो प्रेजेंट डाउट है अगर
वह बच गए अगर मैं क्लियर नहीं कर पाता तो
डेफिनेटली मैं आपको क्लियर करूंगा बट आप
को डाउट नहीं आया क्योंकि मुझे पता है कि
आपको कैसे पढ़ाना है और आपको कहां क्या
डाउट आएगा ये मुझे पता है तो जब हम फाइल
सिस्टम यरार के बारे में पढ़ेंगे ये चीजें
हैं जो मैं नेक्स्ट क्लास में पढ़ाऊंगा तो
यहां पर आपको पता चल जाएगी हर फाइल
डायरेक्टरी का क्या मतलब है जब भी आप काम
करोगे तो पब्लिक प्राइवेट का आपको वैसे ही
क्लियर हो जाएगा और जैसे ही आप उसके अंदर
काम करना सीखो तो आपको वैसे क्लियर हो
जाएगी हां मुझे कहां जाना कहां नहीं जाना
लेकिन एक कांसेप्ट था बेसिक कांसेप्ट मुझे
आपको समझाना था कि आपको क्या करना चाहिए
नक् में और क्या नहीं करना चाहिए अगर आपने
अगर यह समझ में आ गया एक बार रिपीट करके
देखना वीडियोस को जब भीय पर आएगी कल आ
जाएगी आपकी ठीक है तो एक बार दोबारा से
सुन के देखना दोबारा से कांसेप्ट को
रिवाइज करना तो आपका क्लियर हो जाएगा बहुत
ही बेसिक कांसेप्ट है बट बहुत इंपोर्टेंट
तो आज के लिए इतना ही करते हैं बाय बाय
गुड नाइट